One of my local practitioners told me about a Dutch test from Physicians lab.
It doesn't have the organic acid, oat test, like the other brand, the precision analytically.
Does that matter?
Do I need an oat test?
Have you heard of this lab before?
So there are several that have the technology to do a Dutch test.
So you can get it anywhere you want to get it.
And you go, I don't recommend people.
So there's a Dutch complete, and there's a Dutch plus from precision labs.
I can't remember which one of them has the oat test or it does not have the oat test.
I always recommend people get the less expensive one because you don't need the oat test.
But the one thing I do like about the precision analytical one is that it also comes with a cortisol test,
which I think that has value with cancer patients.
So if the one from Physicians lab has that, then biolabies go for it,
or if it's far less expensive, then biolabies go for that.
The only thing that I would say is that if you're going to get a Dutch test done
or any lab test done, there is wisdom in getting it from the same law,
is your comparing results.
So it's using different equipment, and it's the best to get it done at the same lab.
And I've shared that about same thing about getting it done or MRI for a PET scan.
It's always, if you're going to be hearing apples to apples, you're better off getting it done
at the same lab, getting it ultrasound, a breast ultrasound done, it's best to go to the exact same
technique. I know that's not always possible, but certainly getting it done at the same lab
is usually with a possibility. And so if you, if the person asking this question has never done a Dutch
test before, and they're just getting it done, well, you can start using a different lab.
But if you have some desire to do so, whether it's less expensive or whatever your thought process
says, as far as have I heard of that lab, not that I can recall, if I saw there a little
bit, maybe I'd be at the right person, but I'm not going to recall.
I would just continue, if you're going to use that lab, and continue to use that lab, but follow
once too. Remember, just one test is not an adult, be all. You have to compare it with other
scientific symptoms, subjective, and objective things that are going on as well as
comparative tests, comparative labs, over and over, I've seen people get a CBC, you know,
complete metabolic panel done, and there's abnormal findings, and the practitioner never
tells them to do another one. Well, let me have the time they'd ever even address the abnormal
findings, but if they try it, some sort of treatment program to try to adjust, try to address those
abnormal findings, and then you'd ever re-measure whether your treatment program worked to address
those abnormal findings. How do you know? You're doing the right thing. So that would be like,
re-measure.